foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
NBA bets we love we are so back we are
so bad what up everybody welcome to the
show my name is Greg ivory
and next to me
to the right of your screen uh is the
man I like to call MB he is the app
Whisperer
and also next to me to the left of your
screen is the guy we like to call
producer Ryan
the rat Ryan
slander propaganda nonsense you come up
with
you we got to keep you on your toes
weekly Ryan you know how we do here just
like we got to keep you guys on your
toes with these parlays that somehow
some way we just cannot
get a w but that is okay because today
today Ryan thinks we have the worst
slate in the history of Turner Sports
which I don't I I do not agree I I also
I I that's on me I lied it's not in the
history of Turner Sports in in the
history of national television we this
is the worst slate National Basketball
Association basketball I've ever seen in
my life is
Ryan is working on getting fired
yeah he is he's definitely working on
that but right when you have the world
champions playing on the Slate you you
cannot just make that reference and then
think that that's okay like
before the sixth seed in the world
champions the six seed in the West
champions but I'm not even talking you
know I'm not talking about that game I
have made my mark on this show for
months on end promising the people that
we will never have to talk about the
Sacramento Kings because they will never
be on national television and that's why
I just didn't put your foot in your
mouth sir well no you're wrong no I
don't know who at Turner Sports has been
watching this show who's been who's been
like you know what I really this guy's
pissing me off this guy I've had enough
of this producer Ryan rat Ryan
and and put make sure it's the Knicks
game the Knicks out of all teams don't
you want to bet on the neck thanks Ryan
oh no I prefer to bet against both of
those teams it's like that Meme with the
sign where it's like I hope I just hope
both teams lose that's me for tonight
I hate this man oh man what are the
people talking about man what are they
in the crowd in the chat talking about
we've got Adam denoyer just completely
ignoring going uh dear and fox over 26
and a half points I don't want to bet
overs in that game I feel like we should
just bet unders but bowling needs to
bring up a good point earlier that the
Sacramento Kings do not play defense
and they score a lot of points
also um I don't know if it's Turner
Sports too I think it's wbd sports but
that's for another discussion topic I
feel like you're gonna have a rough one
today Ryan so just just making sure you
you have your ducks in a row uh yes I
will be getting emails after the show
that's for sure
working on getting fired
all right let's let's let's get into
this man Drop Your Best Bets for
tonight's TNT games in the chat Warriors
Grizzlies Knicks Kings
Ryan yeah is the people in there talking
are they talking about anything or
should we just get started go to Midwest
Sports dude is saying don't disrespect
the Champs come on now I'm not
disrespecting them that's what I'm
saying bro the Champs are the sixth seed
in the what do you want me to ignore the
facts where they're seated in the
Western Conference
is that what I'm supposed to do I just I
just feel like that's irrelevant it's a
lot of ball left a lot of ball left
they're the Champs so you have to
respect them until that that until
there's new champs Crown bro that's
awesome I said all I said was the
defending champ so I acknowledge the
fact that they are the champions who are
defending themselves are the sixth seed
in the Western Conference
that's it that's it both of those things
are facts
okay so how about if we put it like this
and then we're going to actually get to
this parlay okay because I actually like
the Warriors winning line tonight but
wait how about we put it like this the
team that is ranked six in the west beat
your
Boston Celtics last year in the finals I
live in a what have you done for me
lately type of World Trade unfortunately
yeah that doesn't support your agenda
there you go you see we're learning dude
it only took what is it it's March this
is March right and it took you that long
to figure it out yeah that's right
well what's this what's the first leg
what's the first leg cause uh the
Warriors money line is calling my name
but
says Warriors
um
so that support of your take Greg um I
don't know if we want to start there
because you guys have already talked
about it enough but
ty5 says New York Sacramento game going
over 240 easily we have not put it we
have not put it over under in one of
these parlays before I and I actually
really like that it's just yeah listen
and I I am rooting for both teams to
lose but that's a fun way to kind of
like get involved in that game if we
just do the over I don't know if you
guys are down for that but I am yeah I'm
kind of down too man there are none of
these teams neither team plays any
defense I wonder could we get it down a
little bit after we put some other legs
in for sure um for sure but yeah that's
a that's a number that doesn't scare me
at all
236 yeah exactly yeah and we could play
with it but I let's let's have that one
in there and if we can't move it I think
we're we probably feel good about it no
matter what anyway you guys know who
else is going to show up today
who's that
I don't want to know Stephen Curry
okay I mean yeah I feel like you just
broke you just broke crazy news man I
feel like no no one's ever worked like
that I'm just saying he's he's gonna go
off today
so we should look at his point total
well I thought this wasn't your parlay I
thought this was the business parlay
this is the people's parlay I'm just I'm
just I'm just here you know pushing
agenda
that's too many threes I think for a
parlay but people are in on Steph I
would definitely see like see him see
right it ain't me it's the people
[__] meta oh you you prompted it you
prompted it let's not let's let's not
act like that didn't happen I I did see
uh Prince the trainer say Desmond Bane
two plus threes uh
put in the community and then dropped in
the chat uh Dylan Brooks under 13 and a
half points now a bad guy would say
Darion also gave us a leg last week that
didn't cash
um and it didn't come close but I'm not
a bad guy
I'm not a bad guy I say ridiculous I'm
I'm a Redemption guy shout out Darian I
love you uh
that's what a bad guy would do I'm not a
bad guy
I mean fact facts are effects you know
they call this a weekly we call them
we're gonna start calling you guys out
just so you know I feel like you guys
are part of the show I mean that's what
we do but but darian's not a hater that
that's my problem that's why that's why
I wouldn't do that to Darian darian's
not a hater you know what I mean we do
have some haters in here you know every
week but it's not him
we have some takes we have something no
spreads or money
before those takes nah nah I'm pushing
my agenda I'm sorry I'm so sorry but my
man bagel and locks has been in the chat
giving us an abundance of Dylan Brooks
unders and we talked about it before the
show and I think we should abide by that
and then we can go into the takes that's
all like
I'm just saying we should abide by the
Dylan Brooks under rule
he's playing the Warriors
I don't hate it out there I don't hate
it this is a lot of pressure for Dylan
Brooks and I think I first of all I
think he's a clown second of all I think
that if he is who I think he is he's
going to be trying super hard and I
think that's a great recipe for him to
go two for 20 from the field
exactly
it's plus money too what are you
thinking Ryan why you over there
pondering well B Thompson just dug a
grave for me and reminded me that my my
Dante divincenzo play last week also
God all facts
um if we're spitting facts uh somebody
so you should probably play again play
too
I see some more I see some more takes I
got Darren Dion saying I'd be confident
and tyus Jones over 15 and a half points
I Bryant 1004 tyus Jones points over no
job man absolutely love this play I
think if we can get it at 15 for a leg
here I think that's a really really
strong play tonight okay so then do we
want to do Dylan Brooks oh do you see
Dylan Brooks just jump to 14 and a half
you see take that under is that Bad News
Bears for us though because it's going
is it Bad News Bears Bad News Bears bro
that's better we won under 13 and a half
and it just went up a point
Gregory you don't think everyone you
don't think everyone and their mother
and their grandmother and their
great-grandmother if they have one is
betting on Dylan Brooks under tonight
yeah but Dylan Brooks is the person it
doesn't matter he's not a very good
scorer in my opinion I don't know I say
under we just missed out over for less
money Ryan
we missed out on the plus money it
wasn't gonna happen anyway man
hey I like that we're three legs in that
plus 420. okay so we did get some pushes
over under
um they said if this is the people's
parlay take the under out so oh
um
let me go back let me go back let me go
back whoa and that's only one person
Pete Thompson said if this is the
people's parlay take that over out hey
not your Thompson not your average bad
vibes
says no spreads or money lines or overs
and parlays so that's two people I I
personally like it but but up to you
guys can I first off time out I'm sorry
Ryan time up no no the second person is
not they're not a familiar face to the
show so they just can't come here making
rules to our parlays like come on and
then B Thompson
you got to get some more votes on your
side in order to for us to like you know
switch you you've been here before you
know how it works
I I will say if B Thompson needs to
maybe if you have if you're on your
phone right now and you're in front of a
mirror look in the mirror check the
Vibes and come back with better ones
that's okay listen I think we could do
we could play around and we could do
Dylan Brooks at a different number if we
want if we're like if if we're deciding
that and this also will help out Darian
too an easier chance to get a winner
here because this is the darien like and
I want him to get a winner if we're not
comfortable with that we saw we're
already at 420 with three legs we could
just take a higher number let's say
18 and a half
no way he gets that that's what I'm
saying oh yeah I like it yeah I like
that yeah I don't think I don't think
anyone had any opposition to his under I
think it was more so the over 240 for
the late game oh what
what are we doing why
well this will be the first time we do
have a total within the same game parlay
but this one feels real lucky to me so I
like it okay then we could do two other
plays and then we could tease down the
240 if that's what we really want
because I really like that perfect yeah
that's perfect cool uh do we want to do
one more from this game what are the
people saying uh Rob dog says Desmond
Bane 25 plus
Steph Curry
foreign
but what do you like for Steph Curry
that was that was slick
yeah I was a real slick yeah go up oh
Adam denoyer saying Curry over Curry
over points assistant
you think he's gonna score 30 tonight I
do that's two that's too much I think
for the parlay but I could be
entertained by a 25.
I could also be
I could I think he goes get 30.
I think my problem here G and I don't
think he has any trouble getting the 30.
I don't think this game is going to be
close like I think they may just sit
everyone and do water bottle flips on
the bench and just clown them for the
fourth quarter like I don't know
I don't feel like the Grizzlies the
Grizzlies are getting caught in a really
bad spot Draymond just had his podcast
he went after Dylan Brooks after little
and Brooks went after him like I think
they're gonna try and make a statement
tonight even though they stink on the
road
do we
so you think the Warriors are going to
win yes so why don't we just do that I
feel like I've been saying that yeah
let's do it but but this is my take
though Greg is I don't want to take a
huge Steph Curry number and the Warriors
to win I'd prefer to just take the
Warriors to win and maybe we move on to
something in the late game 25 is a lot
I'm gonna tell you my opinion I'm gonna
tell you this yeah I'm gonna tell you
this 25 is a lock and not feel like 30
is a lot
I really do the way Steph's been playing
coming back from injury yes fresh legs
they're on the road they need this road
win I think he's going to do everything
in his power
so will this team to a win and I think
that that's him playing at an MVP level
caliber and that's scoring over 30
points all right well can I ask you a
question then if we only had to pick one
uh
Warriors to win or staff to go off
Steph
let's ask the audience but I think I
think Steph
everybody's aligned with with Greg no
surprise yeah uh all right their ass
saying 25 bones Curry over 30. Curry to
drop 25 25 lock let's just let's get the
25 in there and see what it looks like
all right I'm in yeah I've been
convinced we're already at 272 so yeah
I like it wait okay wait I like it can I
make a suggestion well we haven't won in
so long should we just
lock this in and just wait for the over
to hit to cash
I don't hate it
it's just three legs just lock the four
let figure four leg lock in and let's
see what's up
um my question my question is and let me
see who dropped this in the chat my
question is
let the people talk Greg I'm sorry I'm
sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry I just had a
good thought good thought uh
damn
where did it go somebody said take steps
threes not the 25 and I can't find it no
somebody no oh it was Bull quizzy said
don't go for 25 for Steph take his
threes I think if Steph if Steph is
going over four and a half threes it's
already 15 points you're gonna tell me
he's not gonna go to the free throw line
and he's not gonna get he's not gonna go
to the basket
yeah don't worry we've been burned we've
been burned too many times on the
three-pointer probably yeah I like the
25. uh my only go ahead go ahead Greg I
was gonna say no no no you can you can
jump right back in I was just gonna say
I'm not with that like
he should score 25 points I agree what I
mean I agree like
I'm with you all right here here's some
takes MBA mbu A-Z says move Ty's Jones
to ten plus and B Thompson says let's
get one more so if we move tyus Jones
down to 10. I like the other leg in
honestly like another one more leg in
the second game yep like a lot you know
what I mean
rebounds or something oh something
that's how we're talking
now we're talking about can we take an
under in in the next game no why because
those teams stink
s
okay wait a second bro if we take it
under while we're taking simultaneously
taking the over the odds are going to be
that's exactly why we don't do it right
okay wait I need a second okay Greg and
I talked off camera okay
you we were just gonna let you pick the
entire parlay for the second game but to
Justice because of your agenda but
what's the point actually has a really
good chance of hitting so don't mess
this up bro all right okay okay easy all
right all right all right all right okay
okay okay all right I'm excited all
right okay all right guys okay so we
need one lucky leg from the second game
Julius Randle 120. there is no chance in
hell Julius Randle gets over 28 points
okay
how do we feel
uh Jaden brunson's not playing
yeah there might be a chance in hell
I don't know I don't I don't love it man
I liked where you were going before you
said something about Jalen Brunson yeah
I know but I think I think I think Greg
Greg was on to something with the
sabonis 10 boards
um
and a half
I know I'm trying to win two but like go
down just go down the 10.
I mean you could really take the 11 and
a half that's easy money it's a bonus
but if you want to be if you want to be
modest
go to go to like we have to win tonight
okay yeah let's let's look like like if
we were if we had won one in the past
few weeks like this could have been fun
and we could have played around but I
don't
I don't know about what about what about
what about Randall six rebounds
foreign
I think he's cleared six rebounds like
in every game he's played let me look
while you while you do some magic on
here well yeah so Hey Jude said I see 10
plus boards for Randall I I don't I
don't like that when the numbers at
eight and a half and we're already
almost at where we need to be
uh somebody said something to fit my
agenda both quizzy uh Randall coming
under and Murray going over
let me see what this looks like in terms
of Randall boards in his last six eight
nine nine eight seven seven
and then two games he did it or one game
before the All-Star break then ten ten
six
10 14 9 11 10. feels like eight boards
feels like a lock to me I don't know
what do you think
no
I think we're overthinking it
go get the bonus plus eight
plus ten eight plus and call it a yeah
whatever plus eight plus ten eight plus
ten plus whatever
but it's a bonus call it a day
and then we can see this to Victory we
can't we can't call it a day because
we're not there yet
is that what
what if we did
10.
10 boards got to get us there eight plus
uh 10 will get us there
'll get us there but I wanted to play
around with the the total
oh
I think we can take something straight I
don't think this is that I
rels no next finder will be tolerated I
mean it has to be
sonoa says it smells like a Kevin herder
game to me
nope
no he sold big time in the Three-Point
Contest I can't do it
do we like this one looks so lucky what
are we overthinking
so what do we have do we have Curry 25
points or 28 yeah it's 25 it's 25. yeah
uh yeah
I don't have this man
Rob dog says he agrees with Greg sabonis
10 plus
rails says don't overthink the goat it's
a bonus look at this man I really don't
understand what we overthinking
under eight and a half
under eight and a half what points
[Music]
he's gone 30. last two but I don't know
what are we replacing in a way the
rebounds
no I I would rather I would rather
replace that with tyus Jones like uh
10 plus it's 10 plus
he's getting 10. and so bonus is nine
nine and a half that's ten plus or ten
lock it in it's kind of the same thing
lock it in
hold on real quick bonus average
but what if okay what if we moved and my
avid's falling apart over here
everything's falling apart my rightness
sign fell down this man this man
averages 12 rebounds a game
you know what that is and cumulatively
over the season he averages 12 rebounds
a game Ryan but we're taking him over in
points and banking on missed shots you
understand that like we have to root for
points and we have to root for missed
shots no this is fine Ryan I think this
let's talk about mathematics usually
when you shoot the wall don't math
usually when you don't do that oh
more when you shoot the ball more that
means there's more of a chance of the
ball
actually not going in the basket and
getting rebounded right or am I wrong
I'm lost I hate math I'm not let's lock
the part lay in and we got this we got
Rel say Ryan you're bugging B Thompson
locked his play in just just like it is
why do we yeah why do we settle but what
if we bumped Mitchell Robinson up to
like under if what Ryan what do you know
about Mitchell Robinson you say you hate
the Knicks
he's a bum
he won't score more than 14. if we took
under 14 and he's a bum
Jones and do that
just like we're not no sabonis so bonus
averages 12. why are we taking him out
only getting 10 rebounds tonight so
we're get okay so we're taking we're
taking some bonus 10 plus I love about
this turn wait wait I love about this
third so we'll let Ryan Cook for this
game and then Greg just whips out his
little bag of tricks and goes uh sabote
is 10 plus math don't think about it
tyus Jones doesn't even average 10 this
year but you're so confident and I'm
scoring 10 tonight because Jaws out
is alive
this this now parlay is a lot we're
locking it in Ryan I'm pulling my foot
down can we alter it can we alternate
the the total points a little bit a
little bit bump it down a little bit no
why can you please put can you please
read the parlay we got to get out of
here
we're up against the clock man get out
of here we let's actually get out of
here all right man don't get me fired
bro I'm tired of this read it
read it we've got the over 240 total
points in the worst game of the century
Knicks versus Kings later tonight we've
got tyus Jones 10 plus points Dylan
Brooks under 18 and a half points Steph
Curry
I believe we have Steph Curry 25 plus
points uh and then uh sabonis over nine
and a half rebounds
plus soccer 31 plus 431 screenshot 50
bucks
screenshot it
we need a uh we need a win
it's going to update in a second for the
screenshot we need to win uh Ryan those
are the that's the parlay guys that's
the parlay so make sure you guys
screenshot it it screenshots wait can I
address one more thing
Mitch is a beast this guy's crazy
Mitchell Robinson stinks like let's not
why are we playing around with this why
is that the hill you want to die on if
you want to come after me for Julius
Randle the guy occasionally scores 40
plus points but you're coming at me
about Mitchell Robinson
Mitchell Robinson brother that's like
these Kings people who come at me about
Sacramento oh we show up to the games
but we you know you don't win the games
you don't win the game you show us
tonight
violin yeah show's over right you just
try to go on your rant at the end of the
show no I gotta interact with the chat
but the chats I mean the chat is crazy
we out of here my name is Greg Ivy
underneath me is Michael Bolin on top of
me is Ryan the producer the rat the rant
guy the
Mitchell Hospital blood pressure guy
Sacramento Kings hater yeah I can keep
going but yo we up out of here man y'all
follow the parlay peace
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]